Lo que vamos a hacer en este video es ver que
si tenemos dos triángulos diferentes donde los
lados correspondientes tienen la misma medida
-es decir, este lado naranja tiene la misma
longitud que este lado naranja, este lado azul
tiene la misma longitud que este lado azul y
también este lado gris tiene la misma longitud
que este lado gris-, entonces podemos deducir
que estos dos triángulos son congruentes entre
sí, con base en la definición de congruencia
dada por transformaciones rígidas. Y para
demostrarlo tendremos que mostrar que siempre
existe una serie de transformaciones rígidas
que mapea el triángulo ABC en el triángulo EDF.
Así que ¿cómo lo hacemos? Bueno, en primer lugar
ya hemos visto en otros videos que si tenemos dos
segmentos de recta que tienen la misma medida,
entonces son congruentes: podemos mapear uno en
el otro usando transformaciones rígidas. Así que
hagamos una serie de transformaciones rígidas que
mapee AB en ED, y ya puedes imaginar cómo lo
haremos. Primero vamos a trasladar el punto A,
de hecho vamos a trasladar por completo este
triángulo de la izquierda de tal forma que el
punto A coincida con el punto E, y entonces el
lado AB va a quedar en esta dirección. Después
rotaremos alrededor de este punto que tenemos
aquí, que podemos llamar A', entonces E = A',
rotaremos alrededor de él de tal forma que el lado
AB coincida con el lado ED. Ya hemos hablado de
esto en otros videos. Por lo tanto este punto
D será igual a B', es decir, el punto donde se
mapea B. Pero la pregunta será: ¿dónde queda C? Si
podemos mostrar que, en efecto, el punto C está en
el punto F, o que, con otra transformación rígida
podemos hacer que el punto C llegue al punto F,
entonces habremos completado la demostración,
ya que seríamos capaces de hacer una serie de
transformaciones rígidas que mapeen este triángulo
en este otro. Para saber dónde queda el punto C,
nuestro compás será bastante útil. Sabemos que
el punto C está exactamente a esta distancia del
punto A, la mediremos con nuestro compás: el punto
C está exactamente a esta distancia del punto A.
Eso significa que el punto C debe estar en algún
lugar sobre esta curva, sobre este arco que
estamos trazando. Todos estos son dos puntos que
están exactamente a la misma distancia del punto
A. Podríamos trazar un círculo completo, pero
creo que ya tienes la idea. Entonces, el punto C,
o podríamos decir C', debe mapearse en algún punto
de este arco, desde la perspectiva de A, ya que
esta es la distancia a la que se encuentra C de A.
Pero, además, sabemos que C está a esta distancia
de B. Ajustemos de nuevo el compás: C está a esta
distancia de B, y si B se mapea en este punto,
es decir, aquí es donde está B', entonces C', o
donde se mapea C, debería estar en algún lugar
sobre esta curva, es decir, podemos ver estas
dos curvas como nuestras restricciones, ya
que C' debe estar en ambas curvas. Por lo tanto,
puede ser justo aquí donde se encuentre F, si mi
transformación rígida nos lleva a que C está en el
mismo lugar que F, con esto nuestra demostración
estaría completa, lo hemos mapeado utilizando
transformaciones rígidas. Ahora bien, la otra
posibilidad es que al hacer estas transformaciones
rígidas C' quede justo aquí, entonces ¿qué otra
transformación rígida podríamos hacer de tal forma
que C' termine en F? Ojo, no olvides que los otros
dos puntos ya coinciden con E y D, así que sólo
nos falta que C' coincida con F. Bueno, una forma
de pensar en esto es la siguiente: sabemos que E
es equidistante tanto de C' como de F, es decir,
esta longitud, a la que le pondremos tres marcas,
va a ser igual a esta otra, ya que, una vez más,
se definen por el radio de este arco; y de igual
manera sabemos que C' está a la misma distancia de
D que F, así que si trazamos una recta que conecte
F y C', una vez más estamos en el caso donde C' no
llega de manera inmediata a F, es decir, donde
C' está de este lado -por así decirlo-, y ya que
el punto E es equidistante a C' y F, entonces
se encuentra en la bisectriz perpendicular del
segmento FC'. La misma idea ocurre para D o B',
esta es la bisectriz perpendicular ya que este
punto D es equidistante tanto a F como a C', de
igual manera E es equidistante tanto a F como
a C', y el conjunto de puntos cuya distancia es
igual a F y C' forman la bisectriz perpendicular
de FC'. Entonces, sabemos que esta recta naranja
es la bisectriz perpendicular de FC'. ¿Por qué es
útil esto? Bueno, esto nos dice que al hacer
las primeras transformaciones para que AB
coincida con ED, si el punto C no coincide con
el punto F y termina por aquí, entonces tenemos
que hacer una transformación extra, tenemos que
hacer una reflexión sobre ED, o sobre A'B' como
quieras verlo, sobre esta recta naranja, y
al realizarla C' coincidirá con F, ya que
la recta naranja es la bisectriz perpendicular,
o podemos verlo de esta forma: esta longitud es
la misma que esta otra, y como es la bisectriz
perpendicular, cuando hagamos la reflexión C'
coincidirá con F. Ahora bien, la reflexión es una
transformación rígida, así que hemos terminado.